it's great to welcome back to the
program today Aaron Lasher who is
co-founder and chief strategy officer at
BRD Aaron was on the program a little
while ago time flies I don't know what I
guess it was like was it six weeks or so
ago I don't even know exactly at this
point yeah I only count days in the
price of Bitcoin so so listen I mean I
think this will be an interesting
conversation so we we've talked before
about how we have sponsors on the
program particularly the YouTube channel
that are in the cryptocurrency space
some are ico some are not and last time
you were on we were clear BRD was was a
sponsor of the david pakman show and
most of my audience sort of gets that we
have sponsors in order to have a show
and most people sort of understand how
programs are funded and they get media
and cryptocurrency etc but very often I
will also get emails from people saying
David you really got to challenge some
of these crypto people more because
there are sort of real serious questions
about the viability and security and
efficacy of the crypto space and lo and
behold Aaron said that he's glad to have
that conversation so is that sort of a
good set up for our talk today that
sounds great
cool okay good so let's get right into
it I mean one of the things that I hear
very often from people in the audience
when we talk to folks from the crypto
space is David you will sometimes
mention as an aside the issue of mining
and the environment but you've got to
take that on much more forcefully as a
program that advocates for reducing our
carbon footprint and trying not to do
damage to the one planet on which humans
currently live so so I mean let's start
there Aaron is this this is a concern
for many people who may believe in the
viability of cryptocurrency conceptually
and politically but they have the
environmental concerns over electrical
use for mining well how should we
approach that conversation those seem
like I think those are valid concerns
but it's really important to put
everything in context so I guess there's
a few points I would make
the first is that it's really not as bad
as people think a lot of the mining is
located in places that have really cheap
hydropower so if you look at I think
some of the more popular locations are
the Sichuan Province in China Washington
State Iceland and a lot a lot of mining
is actually very green I don't I don't
have exact figures for you I don't think
anyone really does but the first thing I
would encourage people to realize is
even if you just look at kilowatts or
kilowatt hours or whatever measure of
power that the network is indeed
consuming a lot of that is renewable and
doesn't really have a carbon footprint
the second would be I think some
justification for it being worth it
so that's more of a comparison of what
does Bitcoin and cryptocurrency provide
to the world and and are we willing to
pay some environmental cost my position
is yes but I I'm happy to debate that
with anyone who disagrees and I know why
they would before we go further if I can
just because it can be hard to kind of
go back and look at these one by one I
think it's so important that we should
recognize that hydropower hydropower
there's not a consensus that hydropower
is quote renewable I mean I think it is
under the umbrella of what we would call
a green energy so to speak or non
carbon-based energy but the renewability
it's not always considered renewable and
in some sense I mean it is something
that at least in particular locations we
can run out of but I think I understand
the point that it is not burning fossil
fuels well you can educate me on that I
I assume that hydropower was relatively
stable and reliable but I guess you're
right the rainfall has an impact and I'm
not a not a not a hydropower expert but
yeah we'll have to look into that some
more yeah so my under my understanding
of it is that it's clean and in the
sense that it doesn't pollute the air
and it's not burning fuels although of
course you know that the creation of the
hydropower plants may be a factor there
but that it is not an endless cycle of
electricity creation on the basis of
waters
movements on the planet but we're both I
think starting to get away from you know
sort of like our core competency on that
particular issue and and I'm completely
ignoring the environmental impact of
actually making one of these power
plants oh there's a lot of there's a lot
of work around that so if we can you'll
just sort of humor me for now I I'll
acknowledge those those concerns but
they're basically saying it's not not
fossil fuels in large part and then I
think the second one I mentioned was
whether it's worth it yeah that's a
little bit more of a subjective
conversation maybe the maybe one way to
get to the bottom of that is look at
what bitcoin can replace because it's
not like the financial system we have
today is is completely cost free or
power free you know what we have even
even down to the the buildings in in
Manhattan you know all of these have a
carbon footprint and in many ways
they're made redundant by by a sort of
mature and useful crypto economy but my
position is that it is worth it even
even acknowledging some some carbon
footprint I suppose a third point is
that it will get better mmm specifically
that the amount of mining is related to
the inflation rate of Bitcoin which goes
down over time and so and then it will
take a while but you know 10 20 years
from now presumably we might actually be
using quite a bit less power
to secure the network so that's that's
another piece and then I mean I guess I
think I'll just leave it there though
those are those are I think
point-counterpoints that that I hear the
most often but I'm happy to dig in if
you think that one of those is
interesting well I think the most
interesting one from the point of view
of someone who would be called like a an
antagonist of cryptocurrency so to speak
as some in my audience are would be this
issue of what what what is is it worth
it and everything has an opportunity
cost obviously anything we do has not
only a direct cost but typically there's
something else we're not doing or
something that on the back end is not
taking place and I guess with
cryptocurrency what I hear from some and
my audience is it's not totally clear to
them
how this apparatus of cryptocurrency
doesn't detract from the stability of
government currencies now if you are not
a particular fan of government backed
currencies and you can point to issues
with government backed currency you
might see that as a positive for
cryptocurrency
but for the majority of people who are
in Western democracies both on the
political left and right with exceptions
for the most part they are comfortable
at least if not actively in favor of
sort of operating businesses or selling
their time to an employer specifically
through government backed currencies
what would be the strongest case to be
made that that should be rethought this
was this was one of the reasons that I
was really pleased that your show
reached out to us to invite us on the
show and actually maybe if I may I'd
like to address the the sponsorship
issue it really does go both ways in the
same way that I think you take care to
only allow sponsors and to promote
products that you yourself are
comfortable with or even use yourself
which I respect we're the same way we
don't we don't want to be associated
with brands or channels that don't make
sense for for what we're doing so
there's a mutual respect there but where
where I felt like you were being treated
unfairly is that you're very transparent
about your sponsors and it's very clear
that the relationship that you have with
them I think you do a great job of
promoting the brands because you at
least believe in or trust the sponsors
that you choose to work with I don't I
didn't see as much so just to be clear
what I'm talking about it was a minority
of your viewers but some of them were
very very negative about your choice to
sponsor a or let a cryptocurrency
company sponsor your show right and I
thought that was totally unfair cuz I
don't I don't see that push back with
like Ling dist right no one no one no
one seems to get upset with with your
other sponsorship choices and I I
thought there's an opportunity there to
to just explore that a little bit if
wanted to well I think it relates to
what I brought up which is that with
something like Ling vez which is a
language learning service for just to
pick once and since you pick that one
sure it's very hard to build any kind of
even reasonable case against learning an
additional language right and so I think
that they're part of the conflict who
comes from is that there is a perception
from many that cryptocurrency is not the
sort of equalizing democratizing force
that some claim it to be and if you
question that then you question well
what is this a force for good or not at
all
right I think that's why the reaction is
that you're I think you're right I think
you're right and and maybe this will add
some fuel to the fire because the the
reason I was excited to work with you is
because I was a little bit surprised
that somebody who I suppose I don't want
to put words in your mouth but I think
is perceived as progressive or left and
has it as a viewership that that largely
reflects that yes would be a fan of
cryptocurrency because at least in the
beginning it is true that it was
intended as as quite a subversive
project and and the target indeed was
Fiat government backed currencies that
would that was the initial beef and more
generally the the banking system so it's
not just that the government has the
issuer is the issue of the currency it's
more the way in which banking works and
how it is largely invisible to the
average person but is very impacts them
and very negative in tangible ways I
just they just don't know that someone's
got their hand in their pocket well I
think that that relates to so the areas
in which I'm very open to cryptocurrency
would be that I recognize the ways in
which the sort of financial industry
industrial complex status quo is bad for
a lot of participants in the financial
system now I also argue that the health
insurance healthcare industrial complex
status quo is bad for a lot of people I
argued that the campaign finance status
quo system is bad for a lot of people so
that was my entry the idea that there
are lots of aspects of the financial
system that are fundamentally not
working for people and maybe there are
elements of cryptocurrency that could
work to mitigate some of those
imbalances although I also have seen
serious commentaries that suggests that
cryptocurrency is going to worse and
wealth inequality rather than reduce it
and I think there's strong cases to be
made on both sides it might personally
I'm I'm less preoccupied with wealth
inequality than I am with absolute
poverty and something that I really like
about cryptocurrency is it is is a
highly inclusive now maybe you have to
have the right frame of mind or the
right influences or the right just be in
the right place in the right time but if
you decided that you you want some as a
method of preserving or growing your
your wealth if you think that that's if
that's one of your objectives and you
think that bitcoin can serve that
purpose you don't have to be rich indeed
a lot of people who today have a
substantial amount of net worth got that
way from buying a few hundred dollars
worth of Bitcoin in 2010 or 2011
so I do see it as highly democratizing
it's highly inclusive it does not
guarantee any kind of equal outcomes and
that that I I readily admit well I think
the Gini coefficient might even be it
might even be worse playing devil's
advocate
here's a way in which it is not so
here's a way in which you could make the
case that cryptocurrency is going to be
a driver of inequality rather than a
than a mitigator although I I'm hearing
you saying that absolute poverty is also
a totally legitimate and valid concern
any technology that requires rather any
financial instrument that requires
access to technology in some way shape
or form access to the Internet and at
least some understanding of currency and
currency exchange and what currency is
is going to keep some people sort of
suppressed and out of it now there are
specific projects including some that
we've talked to that are specifically
working on
bringing cryptocurrency as a way for you
know very rural parts of the world that
don't really have active banking or
financial systems to be able to transact
in in the financial world outside of
barter and I think that that's really
great but at its core some of those just
minimum requirements to even be engaged
in cryptocurrency you could argue are
certainly disfavoring to the poor I I
would I know I why one might think that
but I don't agree and and maybe a good
counter example would be the rapid
adoption of m-pesa in Kenya I think that
most of their population qualifies as
poor and a large swath of their
population is uneducated and yet they
were able to very quickly adopt a
smartphone I'm sorry
mostly flip phones back a cell phone
based payment system that was
essentially backed by cell minutes and
it took almost no time at all for them
to figure out that this was useful and
and and you know they had they had to
use technology they had to have an
internet connection or other cell
connection I don't know maybe maybe I
just I don't underestimate the poor in
that way I think that they're they're
just as capable and savvy as the rest of
us but well a lot of times it's not I
mean so sometimes there will be this
argument you know that there will be so
in to bring it to the American political
landscape for a second not that it
necessarily applies to this you will
often see this routine it's like
predictable in the American political
landscape where someone on the political
left will say hey I've identified a
group that is structurally disadvantaged
in this way or that way
and then someone from the American
political right will come in and say you
are under estimating that group and
you're wanting to help them in some way
is a sort of soft bigotry and
unfortunately it's a really effective
tool for the right to sometimes suppress
really important conversations about
actual structural disadvantages so it's
not so much that I'm saying that the
poor aren't savvy or lack intelligence
or anything like that it's a very 30,000
foot thing where if you need to
understand the concept of different
currencies and have the technological
means to make make this happen it's a
barrier to entry it might not be you
know an extraordinary one but it is at
least a barrier to entry I acknowledge
that but you also look at look at like
Jamie Dimon you know he that there are
there are rich capable educated people
too who have been dismissing
cryptocurrency for a long time in fact
that's been the status quo yeah
poor rich educated uneducated American
not American it's almost it's almost a
miracle at all that any one sort of
figured it out and yeah I mean you're
right but it's hard it's hard for me
because like what we provide is is the
the absolute simplest wallet we possibly
can right and the but what you need is a
smartphone like that that is a physical
asset you need it might be hard for you
to buy one that's a barrier FairPoint
and then secondly you do need a little
bit of open-mindedness / understanding
of current I think you put put it as
understanding of currency or multiple
currencies that too can be confusing so
so I'll give you I'll give you those two
points but I do think that those apply
to the second one of these applies to
people across the spectrum and if you
have any ideas for how to make it more
accessible I'm all yours because yeah I
don't know I don't know you know one of
the things that that this I think also
relates to is so you and I last time
talked a little bit about the word scam
and scams in a cryptocurrency industry
and a common thing that people will
write to me is they'll say David you
know it's not that we distrust your
judgment when it comes to who is or
isn't allowed to be a sponsor of the
show it's more that it can genuinely be
difficult to know in the crypto space
what is and is not a scam do you agree
that even people within the space can be
sort of tricked about what isn't isn't a
scammer or is it easy to figure it out I
think it is usually easy to figure it
out okay with the car
full exceptions the most common scam so
first I think it's just super important
to make this point cryptocurrency itself
is not a scam there are scammers that
use it to their advantage the same way
that email is not a scam but Nigeria and
princes most of them it was probably one
or two real ones most of the Nigerian
princes are scammers and I think also
just before you even make one more
distinction which is there are
cryptocurrency scams that are total sham
project where there is no project and
from the get-go the idea is raise a
bunch of money with an ICO and disappear
there are also projects that are
well-intentioned then just never get off
the ground and that that is a sort of a
different category I think it's
important to point out I agree so let's
take the the Naro scam first which is
the intent to to scam that come comes
generally in two flavors one is the
launching of a project for token and all
these promises are made that are never
actually intended to be fulfilled right
and then the the founders run away with
the money that's a scam that one can be
hard to spot but but if you if you look
at the promises they make typically
legitimate projects will have reasonable
a reasonable roadmap whereas the scams
will just take a kitchen sink approach
and say every buzzword and every cool
thing that could possibly ever be done
to appeal to the broadest number of
people possible so I can acknowledge
that perhaps someone who wasn't close to
the industry might might read or might
might be might might succumb to a lot of
the clever marketing because a lot of
them just pay for a ton of advertising
and just get this sort of emotional have
an emotional response to something they
think they don't want to miss out that's
probably the hardest one to see the one
that's easy to see and it's much more
common is the the the the super high
yield investment scams where they say
they'll pay you you know 5% a week or
10% a month or something like that
returns that are completely unrealistic
in the real world and that just can
never happen and these are otherwise
known by Ponzi schemes anytime you see
returns like that or promises of returns
or guaranteed returns of any type you
need to look very askance the the
reality is I think a lot of the people
that participate in these Ponzi schemes
actually know it's a Ponzi scheme and
they think they're just more clever and
they'll get in and get out before the
last sucker but it doesn't always work
out that way so you mean even some of
the so-called investors some of the
people who choose to participate in an
ICO or a token sale or whatever even
they to some degree know what it is that
they're getting into but they think
they're gonna get out of it and someone
else will be left holding the bag I
would argue it's the its majority Wow
yeah so given the leap libertarian
leanings of cryptocurrency and the space
who if anyone should do something about
that to protect individuals from being
the ones who get sucked in and end up
holding the bag or should it be a sort
of libertarian free market where it's
buyer beware it might it might have to
be the latter just because of the way
cryptocurrency works mean meaning so I
think you're probably hinting at some
kind of structure and regulation similar
to how companies that do an IPO have to
go through an incredible amount of
documentation and crossing T's and
dotting eyes and auditing and all sorts
of things right it still doesn't
guarantee that they're gonna work out by
the way but I think you could try but
even let me put it this way
it's already happened in large part in
the u.s. the SEC has more or less said
unless you create a very clear non
security it's probably a security it's
sort of a little bit of a warning shot
so in the u.s. at least if you're if
you're issuing tokens and selling them
you have to be really careful because
you might fall under SEC regulation but
globally it's hard it's hard to say
because you could be you know two kids
in South Africa and you could you could
be legitimate launching a project and
because it's global there's just nothing
that
like they would just ignore any real
regulation and it just it's unreasonable
but I mean I'd be open to hearing what a
reasonable framework would be I will say
that Hester what's-her-name at the SEC I
think she's doing a lot of good work in
terms of listening to the legitimate
crypto community and trying to trying to
apply light touch reasonable regulations
for cryptocurrency companies so I
actually applaud the SEC on on that on
this yeah and I don't I also don't know
what and you know when you when you're
talking about cross national regulation
it gets very complex and I don't
actually know what it would look like
and that kind of almost gets us to like
the softest version of the scam
allegation which in a way is maybe the
most concerning one for the long term
because the acute scams eventually like
if the acute scams just continue I feel
like something is going to sort of break
and there will be some some significant
change that will drastically reduce them
and maybe it's already happened I would
actually argue but the softest version
of the scam is listen for as long as the
transaction fees on a lot of the
primarily that the the most prominently
traded currencies are high you're not
going to use that currency for
transactions day to day the way we were
told as the case may be for as long as
the transactions take a while and this
varies depending on the currency and how
busy the the exchanges are that's not
going to lend itself to significant
adoption either because oftentimes you
need to pay right away and for as long
as the market prices of these currencies
vary so wildly it's also not a safe
store of value so like that to me is
actually the strongest critique which is
like that stuff's got to be resolved if
this is really going to become what many
were hoping it would three to five years
ago it does it does need to be resolved
I don't I don't see any I don't see any
realistic way for it to resolve other
than just playing out on its own agree
okay well I was gonna I was gonna say if
you if you know a way that it could be
resolved with some exogenous factor
I'd be interested to hear that but I
don't my situation is that I have just
sort of calculated that there's a chance
that this is really going to be a
significant part of the global economy
at some point in the future a bigger
part than it is so I've sort of
calculated what do I believe that that
chance is and what amount of money do I
think it makes sense to sort of risk on
that versus cash real estate my business
stocks bonds etc but I sort of recognize
like as long as things are the way are
now I don't see my cryptocurrency
holdings as an investment I really do
see them as a gamble I don't see my
cryptocurrency holdings as currency I
would use for transactions I see it as
I'm just gonna let it sit and sort of
see what happens but I agree with you I
don't actually know what would get that
fundamental reality to change about the
transaction costs to change as well as
the price fluctuations I don't know I
think that if we just sort of roll the
tape forward and instead of 50 to 100
million people with cryptocurrency it's
a billion sure it will it will provide a
stabilizing effect on price so just just
taking the volatility first over time if
more people adopt it in a similar
fashion to yourself whether they call it
a gamble or an investment or a
speculation it doesn't doesn't really
matter as long as it's in the hands of
more people the volatility will go down
over time and I think that maybe
addresses the store value issue the the
spending part I think it's a little it's
a little different because people do
like to spend it when it goes up in
price after a certain after a certain
point so there's sort of this switching
point during these bubbles where all
these holders become sellers and/or
spenders it's just it stands to reason
that if you had a thousand dollars last
year and now it's a hundred thousand
dollars that you won't mind you know
buying a nice steak dinner so that I
think they're it I think you can you can
still have this payment dynamic
regardless of the price that will
and indeed like people use it I mean III
pay my my neighbor to walk my dog every
day in Bitcoin and she loves it and she
tells me every day how close she is to
the next you know the next goal that she
said and she doesn't care what the
prices now I understand that's not like
a mainstream use case and not everyone
feels that way but uh yeah I mean you
can it's one of those things where like
I would probably agree with you if I
didn't have any data but if you just
look at the public blockchains people
are using them all the time and so it
they just do and and that's that's a
fact as far as the transaction fees if
the user base goes from a hundred
million to a billion what happens to
transaction speeds and transaction times
it depends on the coin bitcoin is the
biggest and so that's the one that's
getting the most pressure I really I
really don't know David because that's
right because we're talking about
yeah the volatility volatility will go
down if you go from a hundred million to
a billion users but we saw during the
nineteen thousand dollar Bitcoin bubble
in December of I guess it was seventeen
that fees were absolutely off the charts
and that could again become a problem
yes the good news is that there are a
lot of ways out of the woods it's not
it's not that we don't know how to solve
it it's that different solutions have
different trade-offs one solution is
that people just use intermediaries like
I'll give an example so coin base is one
of the largest Bitcoin cryptocurrency
companies and if you have your money
with them you can send money to friends
that are also with them for no fees
right so they'll just they'll just debit
and credit Bitcoin balances and then if
you want to actually hold the Bitcoin
which we encourage and that's the
solution we provide then you do have to
pay a transaction fee or the a
transaction fee has to be paid for the
network well like I said different coins
do different things so so Bitcoin cash
was was the the brother or sister of
Bitcoin however you want to look at it
they parted ways and it was it was
largely over this issue of transaction
fees and as things stand today Bitcoin
- has more capacity for transactions
than Bitcoin whether or not that will
give it a competitive edge time will
tell but you asked the second question
which was time time to complete
transactions again depends on the coin
if your aim is really quick to get a
confirmation Bitcoin and Bitcoin cash
have an average 10 minute interval and
and if the networks are jammed up then
your transaction might get punted a few
more intervals forward so it could be
could be hours or days sometimes it's
not a good experience it's not a good
thing so that mean that that's part of
why I enjoy this industry so much is he
just every coin gets to compete on its
own merits and then we'll see what
happens we will indeed and we've been
seeing I mean over the last I guess I I
noticed that only a few days ago but I
guess there's been a bit of a rally in
in a lot of the coin prices over the
last week or so and immediately you know
I start to get texts from people saying
what are you doing what are you doing
and usually my answer is number one I
have no advice for you right and number
two I'm doing nothing I'm just waiting
and if it goes back down I'll regret not
having sold and if it goes up I'll feel
like I actually know what I'm doing
right it is there I mean when you see
these rallies and declines and everybody
starts commenting on what it is that's
going on nobody knows right I mean
nobody has any idea not really yeah sort
of I think I think I do but but yeah
it's like the stock market particularly
that the shorter the time frame yeah so
what's happening tomorrow or the next
day no one knows now long-term you get
it you have a better chance right if you
if you sort of do the math in your head
and think how much of how much concret
of currency carve out of the rest of the
economy in terms of value and you look
five ten twenty years ahead you actually
you'll do better that way because it
cancels out all the noise but yeah in
the short term good luck we have been
speaking with Aaron Lasher who is the
co-founder and chief strategy officer at
BRD Aaron I really do appreciate you
talking to me again I think it was a
very interesting conversation thanks for
having me on again David